[Applaudissements]
rappeler cette histoire
enora qu'est ce qui s'est passé
washington vous nous avez révélé quelque
chose qu'elle tpm paix par au ski à
partir de 20h50
on est tout émoustillé garder cette
révélation effectivement pour le prime
pendant cette journée c'est bluff ou pas
bluff dans leur rappeler de tout ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé c'est que
voilà après une journée tournage le soir
on s'amusait bien d'aller dîner tous
entre deux équipes et jean-rené flore aa
parce que si l'on va les entendre toutes
les missions merci beaucoup chacun voit
là on va boire un verre tous ensemble
chacun va se coucher et puis bonne
quarantaine de minutes après je suis en
pyjama et tout je suis sous la couette
et j'entends même pas quelqu'un toqués
j'entends quelqu'un gratter vraiment
gratter elle a rejeté parce que gratter
ça peut être gilles avec son nez alors
j'ai tout de suite pensé à j 100 m mais
j'ai ouvert la porte et j'ai vu notre
notre cas la pub lui qui m'a dit voilà
qui m'a tendu la main la proposition est
alors de câlins et alors alors j'ai
refusé mais c'est pas bluff non non non
il ya eu décès pour les bleus ouais
ouais mais n'a jamais juste envie d donc
décidé d'embrasser une fille non bah mon
service m'a parlé de plus mais
j'aimerais la plus belle vous auriez
débat et une perruque
valérie c'est génial vous embrasser une
fille et un garçon même temps
c'était tout le temps dans sa chambre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]